what's up guys today we're gonna be
taking you and look at the coarser of
engines or RGB PDR for thirty two
hundred grand
it's a 16 gigabyte kit and let's see
what's inside so guys on the front it
has a picture of the RAM and the logo of
course there and the name in the side
same thing name Ram name Forster brand
same thing on the back and has some more
technical information in main languages
and you can there's two windows ABC the
grandmother and on a slide same thing
the other side in the top this is RGB
lighting and there is a little peel off
tower right there and there's also a
little toggle on the water and the
corset logo let's get into this
so once you get the tab off the whole
top is comes off and then the RAM just
slides out there's a two sticks of
vengeance our GB RAM and it opens
there's a little corner right here it
makes it easy for a finger to go into
and you'd open the whole team up so guys
here's the coarser RGB Ram
well guys I hope you enjoyed that quick
unboxing of the Corsair Vengeance RGB
Ram
I'm gonna be going through the software
and see how it performs and seeing the X
and feed profiles stuff like that on my
review see if you guys want to see that
make sure to click the link in the
description for my full review of this
Ram but that's it for now so until next
time guys bye
[Music]